- I was very nervous,
I was like, "I wanna say his name right."
I love the German language.
- Yeah, but the last name is-
- Schweighofer.
- Schweighofer is fantastic.
And the last name is like,
even for my family,
sometimes unpronounceable.
(Kelly laughing)
- Is that after alcohol is involved?
- Yeah, after a lot of alcohol.
It's like
(mumbling)
(Kelly laughing)
- That's probably how most
Americans sound when they say it.
Well meet Jamie, have
y'all ever met before?
- Very nice to meet you.
- I'm a huge fan of both
of you and it's crazy.
Today everyone in Germany
was like, "Hug everyone."
It's crazy.
- I love it.
Well, "Army of Thieves" looks
great and funny as well.
So did you direct this one?
Is that what I hear?
- Yes, I directed this movie.
- [Kelly] That's amazing.
- Yeah, because we did "Army Of The Dead",
and then at that time, my
character in that film,
it's name is Ludwig Dieter,
the Safe Cracker and...
(audience cheering)
- Very mysterious.
- Thank you so much.
- Thank you.
(Kelly clapping and laughing)
I am amazing.
- I am.
And one day Zack Snyder
called me and said,
"Matthias, we have an idea
for a potential spinoff for the character,
so would you direct the film?"
And I said, "Yes, but
who's the character?"
And he said, "It's Dieter."
And I said.
- Oh, my gosh.
- Thank God.
(audience cheering)
- That's so cool.
- [Mathias] I left there
clapping all the way.
- Are you getting recognized
everywhere right now?
(Mathias speaking foreign language)
(Kelly laughing)
- When there are Germans involved, a lot.
There's a restaurant I love here in LA.
Can I tell the story?
- Yeah.
- I was in a restaurant,
it was super relaxed
and I had breakfast and they were like
a group of people looking at me, you know?
And I thought, Americans,
they know me, that's cool.
- Oh, my God, this is my moment.
- Yeah, but after a few seconds,
I recognized, okay no, they're Germans.
And then when they saw
me recognizing them,
they thought like, okay,
let's go over there.
"Can we have an autograph or a picture?"
So I took a picture
in front of all the other
Americans in the cafe.
But as you watch their faces,
it's like, "Who is he?"
(Kelly laughing)
(audience laughing)
"Who is this guy?"
- [Kelly] I love that.
- [Jamie] They're gonna know soon.
- I love that though.
You find your people
wherever you go though.
I feel that about Texans.
I'm from Texas here and everywhere I go,
even if you don't know each other,
you're like, "You're from Texas?"
You don't even know each other,
but you're like, "We're so similar."